I remember during the pandemic right
everything shut down no Sports going on
I'm like
like we about to find out if these
[__] could really talk for a
living and when you guys found a way to
talk about not Sports yeah every day
every day like y'all listen man that
[__] wasn't intentional we should have
had time off
but we didn't I mean everybody had time
it was you and nurses First Take was on
every day every five days a week
throughout the Pandemic those two months
where there was nothing but sports
that's why let me tell you something
that's why Dana White that's why he was
such a Salvation for us because remember
to talk about no he was pushing yeah for
the sport to keep going yeah and that
gave us something to talk about yeah
that gave us something to talk about it
was and then him the two people I'm most
grateful to because of provide because
they provided us supports during the
pandemic was Dana White
and Michael Jordan's last name bro when
the Last Dance came out yeah it couldn't
have been a more perfect time I remember
there's a video of me somewhere I was I
my wife is videotaping me without
realizing it and I'm explaining her the
rules of how I'm gonna watch this show
right and she's going but what if I have
any questions I'll go there are no
questions
we're watching and you got to wait no
she's no she asked [__] questions
why is his wife dating somebody
or whatever everybody
yeah
but that was that was like this perfect
okay we you're older than me but I'm
still old enough to be at a time where
it's like there were a few things on TV
that everybody cared about right and
when the finals came around or the
playoffs came out that was it now
there's everybody's on Tick Tock
Instagram there's a million different
things that they can be distracted by
okay but when that [__] uh when that
special came out when that documentary
came out it felt like the world stopped
man and if it was like I don't know if
like the world is organized in this way
I don't know if there's a higher I don't
know what it is but it was something
like hey y'all gonna [__] recognize
Jordan's greatness there's a reason
these kids are wearing these sneakers
they never watch them play once yeah and
I was I would even talk to young people
about it and they'd be like oh I see why
you yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
like that but you know because so many
of them are lost so it's just so sad you
know I mean because they want they
listen they talk about LeBron they talk
about these other players talk about
even Kobe and then you know MJ you know
better than MJ no they were not yeah MJ
was on another level bro you know what
I'm saying like listen LeBron is
universally respected Mount Rushmore
basketball greatest small forward that
ever lived or gonna go down his all-time
greatest score in NBA history all this
other [__] all true
but you know something he ain't 6-0 in
the NBA Finals with six NBA Finals MVP
he doesn't you know you know Michael
Jordan doesn't have a choke performance
on his resume but you just call it what
it is against Dallas 2011. that was not
LeBron's China moment that's just the
truth and then not only that and I often
use this
LeBron is universally and unquestionably
highly respected Jordan was feared he
scared the living hell out of you you
didn't want to go up against Jordan you
want to know parts of him and Jordan
would do things to
demoralize you in such a way that you
didn't even want to think about going up
against him again I mean the things that
this man the things that this man used
to do to people to opponents it's unreal
man and I'm like I saw it yeah I saw it
they could talk to me they could talk
whatever they want until the cows come
home Michael Jordan's number one
LeBron's number two yeah
between two and three between him and
Kareem Abdul